ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนั้นก็เยียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้า
วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 1
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
สิงหาคมเปลี่ยนแล้วเนาะปิดแล้วค่ะเปลี่ยน
แล้วเปลี่ยนเดือนปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ตีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะกะเมื่อวานนี้
วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
31 เดือน
ต่อไปคะเดือน
สิงหาคม
เมื่อวานนี้
เบียนเดือนก.ค.
ปีพต
มีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศปีพ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 2 เดือน
เดือน
สิงหาคม AE พ.ศต.ค.ปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้
เวลา
11:00 นแต่
11 โมงกี่นาที
10 นาทีค่ะ
11:10 นนะคะตอนกลางวันตอนกลางวันนะคะตอน
นี้ที่ประเทศไทยเนี้ย
ร้อนไหมคะคือฟ้าร้อนแบบ 40 องศาเซลเซียส
ดวงอาทิตย์ใหญ่มากร้อนที่ประเทศไทยเหนียว
ร้อนแบบ 4  19 องศาเซลเซียส
ฟิลไลต์นั้นอ๋ออ๋อฟิวไหลนะคะ
ขาเซลเซียส
ร้อนมาก
ร้อนครูฟ้าแล้วเวลาที่
ร้อนร้อนๆนะคะครูฟ้า
ชอบทำอะไรอ่ะ
อุ๊ยเวลาอ่ะ
วันเวลาที่ร้อนเนี่ยหนึ่งนะฮะกูชายชอบกิน
ไอติม in นี้
ก็ว่างไอติมมันเย็นใช่ไหมไอหายเป็นมัน
เย็นหน้าให้เธอมันไอติมและน้อง
แป้งว่าเธอเรียนแบบนี้ก็ได้นะคะแบบนี้
เนี้ยไอ้ติมเหมือนกันแต่เว่นเย็น of  2
ล่ะคะทำอะไรเวลาที่แบบองค์ประเทศไทยแต่
มันร้อนมากๆ 40 องศาเซลเซียส
สองฝาก็
มีอะไรคะใส่หมวกอาบน้ำค่ะคุยอันนี้คือ
อะไรเหรอ
เลือกปรับบัวมั้ยปรับมุม 5 อันนี้กูฟ้าไง
ปลาอ่ะ
ผม
ขอ
กับวัวนะแล้วกูก็อาบน้ำ
[เพลง]
โปรดีเลยค่ะครูฟ้าเค้าไม่มี 3 ค่ะพอแล้ว
กูอยากได้แค่นี้แหละ
เพราะว่าวันนี้เนี่ยผู้หญิงก็จะมีคำถาม
เกี่ยวกับอาบน้ำได้แล้วสั่งครูฟ้าแต่ว่า
ครูเราไม่ได้มาคุยเรื่องอาบน้ำนะคะว่าเรา
เคยคุยกับนักเรียนไปแล้ว
แล้วก็หญิงมีคำถามอะไร
คำถามอะไรเอ้าคุยอีกมีคำถามว่าถ้าฮ่าๆครู
ฟ้าอันนี้นะคะโทรฟ้า
คุณครูฟ้านะกำลังอาบน้ำแล้วก็สระผมวันนี้
มืออยู่ที่นี่ที่นี่สระผม
นี่ก็จะมีฝักบัวใช่ไหม
ประมงวัว
ที่ไม่ใช่ไฟนะคะนักเรียนนี้เป็นผักบัวฝัก
บัวในก็จะมีนาน้ำ
ใช่มั้ยน้ำออกมาเวลาที่ครูฟ้าอาบน้ำแล้ว
ก็สระผมสมัยเวลาภูพระอาบน้ำเนี่ยภูฟ้าก็
จะเปิดน้ำใส่เปิดน้ำก็จะมีน้ำงามแต่ว่า
เวลาพอครูป๊าสระผมกูกันปิดน้ำ
ใช่หางว่าก็ต้องปิดให้มันจะเป็น
แบบนี้ใช่ไหมค่ะเขาก็ต้องปิดน้ำเออปิดน้ำ
แล้วก็
ถ้าสมัยสระผมสามผมก็จะมีแชมพูแต่นั้นปาก
ผมแล้วถ้ากูฟ้ากำลังสระผมอยู่สระผมเสร็จ
แล้วมีชมพูกูฟ้าก็เปิดน้ำเปิดน้ำเปิดแต่
น้ำเนี่ยครับบิดเปิดแล้วแต่น้ำ
น้ำไม่ไหล
น้ำไม่ไหลได้ยังไงผู้หญิงกูป่าวมีแชมพู
แชมพูแชมพูแชมพูแชมพูเยอะมากเฮ้ยมีแชมพู
อยู่ที่ผมมันซักทีสบู่อยู่ที่ตัวกูฟังคิด
ลั้ลลาแล้วก็แบบเปิดน้ำ
น้ำไม่ไหลแล้วครูฟ้ากำลังสระผมอยู่
ครูฟ้า
มีจุดทำยังไง
ไปก็ทำยังไงกูฟ้าตกใจไหมตกใจคู่หญิงมันก็
จะ
ทำไมทำไมน้ำเนี่ยทำไมน้ำไม่ไหลทำไมน้ำไม่
ไหลทำยังไงทำยังไงทำยังไงดีทำให้อย่างดี
ครูฟ้าจะทำยังไงครูคำเฮ้ยผู้หญิง
กรุงฟ้าน่ะกำลังจะกำลังสองผมอยู่ใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วน้ำไม่ไหลก็ผงที่ผมเนี่ยก็มีฟองฟอง
สมัยนักซองฟองยาสระผมกูฟ้าก็มือก็รูด
รูปเขาฟ้อง
โรงเรียนบอกไม่ใช่ครูฟ้าอันนี้ครูหญิง
มีรูหญิงครูป๊าเนี่ยคิดว่า
ครูฟ้าจะทำยังไง
เอโต้
ครูขอให้ผู้หญิงคิดเหรอคะว่ากูฟ้าจะทำยัง
ไงเอง 4  avc เปล่านี่เองดีสิ่งมีหลายโชย
มามี 1  2  3 ไหมคะนี่หนึ่งก็ได้งานนึงก็
ได้อันนี้คือฟ้าจะทำยังไง
หนึ่งเมียกูฟ้าก็จะ
อันนี้อะไรคะภูฟ้าฟ้านะคะ
อาทิตย์ตัว
ผู้หญิงหรือว่ามีฟ้าจะมีกระดาษแล้วก็ปิด
ออก
เรามีผ้าจะตัวใช่มั้ยคะนักเรียนไปสัตว์
ตัวนะเพราะว่าเราผิดมีผ้าใช่ไหมอ่ะ
ใส่ไว้ตัวแล้วก็จะเดินลงบันได
แป้บเดียวคะเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวๆที่หัวลุกค้ายัง
มียาสระผมอยู่นะใช่คู่หญิงใช่กูมียาสระผม
ใช่ไหมเออ
เขาก็จะเดินเดินๆ
เราก็จะอ่าเอาน้ำใช่ไหมว่ามีน้ำ
น้ำดื่มอะเหรอคะใช่หาน้ำดื่มอยู่ในตู้
เย็น
ห๊า
[เพลง]
โหร 51 ตู้เย็นเลยเหรอคะ
ไม่มีเอา
ให้กูก็จะหยิบน้ำใช่ไหมที่อยู่ในตู้เย็น
แล้วหยิบน้ำหยิบน้ำแล้วก็ไปกันล้างไปล้าง
ล้างล้างแชมพูออกล้างแชมพูออกล้างแชมพู
ออกอันนี้คือหนึ่งก็อาจจะล้างได้นิดหน่อย
นะนักเรียนค่ะแต่ว่าก็ดีกว่าโอ้นี่ค่ะ
ไซส์ไม่เป็นไรเพราะว่าน้ำของครูฟ้าเนี่ย
น้ำในตู้เย็นเนี่ยมันจะประมาณ
1.5 ลิตรสมัยหนึ่งขวดประมาณ 1.5 ลิตร 1
ถูกต้องอันนี้หนึ่งนะคะก็คือเดินลงไปเอา
น้ำในตู้เย็นมาล้างผม
2  2 ทำยังไง
ก็จะมีมีโทรศัพท์ค่ะกูฟ้าเอาโทรศัพท์เข้า
ห้องน้ำด้วยเหรอคะเอ่อใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงก็เอา
โทรศัพท์เข้าห้องน้ำด้วยนะคะก็จะมี
โทรศัพท์
เดี๋ยวร้านกูฟ้า
ค่ะเผื่อหลายปีเคชั่น
เปิด Application อันนี้ค่ะ
แอพพลิเคชั่นอะไรคะครูฟ้าอ่ะ
เอ่อเอ่อสว่างนะเซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นนักเรียน
on
เปิด Application เซเว่นอีเลฟเว่น
ทำไมเอ้าสั่งน้ำเปล่าไง
น้ำฟ้าเนี่ยในตู้เย็นใช่ไหมมี 1 ขวด
มาก็ต้องสั่งจากเซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นนะคะสั่ง
น้ำน้ำน้ำน้ำใช่ไหมสั่งน้ำ
วินแกลลอนนะครับเธออาจจะเป็นแบบนี้ก็ได้
นะน้ำแบบใหญ่ๆเยอะใช่ไหมกูป่าอันนี้เนี่ย
อ้าฤทธิ์สวยไม่มีน้ำเนี่ย 5 ลิตร
ก็นั่งน้ำมาจากเซเว่นอีเลฟเว่น
หาเท่าไหร่ฟ้าสั่งน้ำสัตว์เซเว่น
อีเลฟเว่นครูฟ้าก็ต้องรออย่า
ให้รอนานๆแล้วก็มียาสระผมอยู่ที่หัวด้วย
เหรอคะถูกต้องให้ผู้หญิงต้องรอ
ก็อันนี้นะคะ Choice ที่ 2 ของ groupon ๆ
แล้วก็ตา 3  3 ครูฟ้าทำยังไงคะกูพาก็จะ
เดินลงมา
เดินๆ
เดินลงมาที่ไหนอุดอันนี้บ้านของป่านะค่ะ
กูก็จะเดิน
ไปเพื่อนบ้าน
ไปหาบ้านข้างๆบ้านกูฟ้าหรอใช่เราไปหาบ้าน
ข้างบ้านกูป๊า
ไปทำไม
ก็คือๆผู้หญิงเนาะโจทก์ว่าบ้านบ้านหลัง
โอ้นี่นะเป็นบ้านผู้หญิงจะมาบ้างผู้หญิง
กลับบ้านกูไปอยู่ติดกันอ่ะผู้หญิงก็กำลัง
บ่เล่นโทรศัพท์อยู่
ก็ค่อยๆ
นี่ก็เปิดประตูกุ้ย
555 เดี๋ยวหาน้ำใส่ได้ไหมคะ
ชื่อกูฟ้าแสดงข้างแล้วก็อาบน้ำขอ
น้ำไม่ไหล
นี่อิอิเอ้าผู้หญิงเนี่ยก็กำลังอาบน้ำ
แล้วก็สระผมแล้วพบเปิดน้ำไม่ไหล
กูมาเดินกลับบ้านนะฮะฉันจะเอาหัวปลาคะคุณ
อยู่บ้านใกล้กันบ้านครูฟ้าน้ำไม่ไหลแจ้ง
ครูหญิงก็
น้ำไม่ไหลเหมือนกัน
คือปกติแล้วอ่ะบ้านกูฟ้าเนี่ยน้ำไม่ไหล
บ้านคนอื่นจะน้ำลายเอาหรอ
เผื่อเขาจะมีแทงค์น้ำเนี่ยเออใช่ใช่ๆอะ
บางบ้านเนี่ยยังไม่ได้อาบน้ำไม่ได้อาบน้ำ
จากฝักบัวอย่างเดียวไงเขาจะมีผังด้วย
ใช่ไหมมีถังน้ำที่เอ้าต์เวลาน้ำไม่ไหลก็
มีถังแล้วก็มีขันตั่งอาบได้อะไรบ้างผู้
ป่าวไม่มีใช่ไหม
บอกว่าน้ำไม่ไหลบ่อยนะคะแต่ผู้หญิงเหรอก็
เนอะเอาไม่ไหลกูก็เดินกลับบ้านแล้วเรียน
สานสองต่อ
ไปข้อ 2 ไปของไปสั่งน้ำจากเซเว่น
อีเลฟเว่นให้มาส่งที่บ้าน
น่ารักๆคว้าไม่มีค่ะท่านผู้หญิงก่อนว่า
ผู้หญิงจะทำยังไงถ้าครูหญิงน้ำไม่ไหล
คุยก็บอกกูฟ้าไปแล้วไงอะไรฮะคุยนะคะคุย
อาจจะไม่มี 1  2  3 นะผู้หญิงก็จะมีอ่ะ
เก่งหนึ่งก่อนแล้วกันหนึ่งเนี่ยถ้าเรา
กำลังอาบน้ำอยู่ใช่ไหมเราก็สระผมแล้วก็
เปิดฝักบัวสวยเปิดฝักบัวแล้วน้ำไม่ไหล
เดี๋ยวบ้านผู้หญิงได้มีอันนี้นะคะเอาออก
ไปก่อน
ครูหญิงน่ะนะคะก็รอรอประมาณ
สระเอา
รอประมาณ
3-5 นาที
รอก่อนแต่ว่าเราเปิดแล้วแบบนี้น้ำไม่ไหล
เราก็รอรอรอๆก็มีมียาสระผมอยู่ที่หัวนะก็
พยายามเช็ด
คุณแม่ยาสระผมเนี่ยไรหลายๆลงมาที่ด่าแล้ว
ก็รอรอ
3-5 นาที
แล้วเปิดไหมเปิด
ก็หนาวไม่หลัย
ทำยังไงอยู่ผู้หญิงต่อ
นี่นักเรียนประเทศไทยเนี่ยประเทศไทยหรอ
นักเรียนก็มีอะไรวะนึกออกอย่างนึงผู้หญิง
อีกแล้วอ้ะ
นักเรียนบอกว่าครูหญิงผู้หญิงคิดไม่ออก
ใช่ปืน
ไม่ใช่
กูฟังว่ามีวิธีอะไรถ้าเขาไม่รอไงเฮ้ยไม่
รอรอไม่ก็ไม่ได้ก็รอได้แล้วผู้หญิงวิธี
นี้มันก็รอได้นะฮะกูคิดว่าก็ถ้าเกิดสระผม
อยู่ใช่ไหมคะและก็ใช้อันนี้หารักผู้หญิง
ออก
ไอเดียดีไอ้เดย์ดีคู่ฟ้ายาสระผมเนี่ยมัน
จะได้ไม่ไหลหลายๆเข้าตาใช่ไหมงั้นมันจะ
แบบ
แปลกตาเออใช่ๆอะดีแล้วก็รอแล้วก็
วันนี้
ครูฟ้าใช่ไหมคะมีหมวกคลุมผมเนี่ยโอ้ผู้
หญิงรอได้ประมาณแบบ
หนึ่งชั่วโมงเลยแหละ
ใช่
รอเลยอ่ะรรและเปิดรองแล้วก็เปิดยังไม่ไหล
หาแต่ถ้าไม่มีใช่มั้ยไม่มีหมวกคลุมผม
เนี่ยรอ 3-5 นาทีแล้วน้ำยังไม่มามันยังไง
คุยก็
วิ่งคิดนะเหมือนกูป่าวไม่เอานะคะอุ้ยก็จะ
เอาอ่ะไม่รู้
เอายัง
ออกอ๋อก็เอาน้ำออกไปนะคะยาสระผมจะเป็นไง
เอาน้ำออกไปแล้วก็ไปเอาน้ำออกไปให้หมดมัน
ก็ให้แบบเอ่อที่หัวเราเนี่ยนะคะเราอาจจะ
มีผ้าใช่ไหมคนจะมีอ่าอันที่สองเนี่ยก็จะ
มีผ้าผ้า
ที่เราไว้เช็ดผมผ้าเช็ดหัวให้เราก็เอารูด
เอาอย่างเนี้ยผมที่เป็นน้ำออกหน้า 16
หลังเอาผ้าเช็ดหัวเนี่ยถ้าใช้ผมเนี่ยเช็ด
เช็ดๆให้ผมเนี่ยมันแห้งแบบนี้แห้งไม่มี
น้ำแล้วก็ทำตัวก็พาเช็ดไปเช็ดให้แห้ง
แล้วก็ใส่เสื้อใส่กางเกงแล้วก็ไปนอนนอน
หรอนอนรอรอน้ำม้างู
มีผู้หญิงรู้ไหมอะไรคะเวลาบ้าน coupon
เนี่ยมา
นี่บ้านหูฟ้า
เวลาบ้านกูป๊าน้ำไม่ไหลเนี่ยอาไม่ไหล 1
วันนะคะ
ไม่ใช่ 1 ชั่วโมง
โอเคฮ่าๆหนึ่งวันพุธว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยอาบ
น้ำประมาณก๋วยเตี๋ยวอีกแล้วน้ำดึกด้วยสิ
อาบน้ำประมาณรัก 20:00 น
ใช่มั้ย 20:00 นแล้วก็รอก็คือเช็ดผมเช็ด
ตัวเสร็จแล้วแต่ยังอาบน้ำไม่เสร็จนะ
20:00 น 21:00 น 22:00  23:00 นนะคะ
11:00 นเปิด
น้ำกว่านี้น้ำนะคะนักเรียนถึงว่าน้ำไม่
สวยเลยอ่ะเอ้าน้ำเนี่ยก็ไม่ไหล
5 ถูกแล้วนะ
แนะนำก็ไม่ไหลเอายังไงผู้หญิงก็คงเหมือน
กูฟ้าล่ะค่ะเปิดตู้เย็นเปิดตู้เย็นนะเปิด
ตู้เย็นนะคะเราก็เอาขวดน้ำ
น้ำเนี่ยน้ำ 1.5 ลิตรเนี่ยอ่ะค่ะเอามา
ล้างผม
ตู้เย็นผู้หญิงน่าจะมีน้ำอันเนี้ยอย่าง
น้อยละหนูจะมีประมาณ 4 ขวดในตู้เย็นก็
โอ๊ะ
ส่วนตัวตัวเนี่ยคิดว่าเอาน้ำเราก็ใส่ผ้า
แล้วก็เช็ดเอาเฮ็ดเหงาแต่ผมเนี่ยเอาน้ำ
ล้างนะคะก็คงต้องทำแบบนี้แหละน้องให้ล่อ
กันเหมือนแม่ล่ะค่ะแล้วนัดเรียนหรอคะถ้า
นักเรียนกำลังอาบน้ำแล้วก็สั่งผมอยู่แล้ว
น้ำไม่ไหล
นักเรียนจะทำทำยังไง
[เพลง]
ไม่ใส่ลงไปนอนเลยเหมือนผู้หญิงเอาก็ไม่
รู้นะจอคอมเม้นบอกเราได้นะคะแต่ว่าวีดีโอ
นี้คุยกับกูป๋าก็ไปก่อนเนาะมาเจอกันใหม่
วิดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ